i know somebody asked him a question on
the minecraft as he's playing and they
said
said to him have you read the quran and
he was like have i
read the quran no what
are you mad about please
before you read the quran please do one
thing i did this [ __ ] to islam
before you open to read the quran
check out this arabic quote from brother
ishmael may allah bless him inshallah
with 20
discount i'm going to give the discount
link at the description box inshallah
check out inshallah to learn quran
to him pewdiepie pewdiepie is somebody
who plays games or
minecraft awareness quote um and he does
reaction
videos to playing him and people like
watching his reaction videos
to the reaction of the game you know
what i'm going to do today i've
downloaded a random shooting game i
don't have these games on my phone
and i'm gonna be playing that while
interacting yes hope hope is crazy and
hope you guys enjoy it
um and hopefully i will not get uh done
for uh training for to be a uh
jihadi or terrorist whether you guys
want to call it and get sent to the
guantanamo bay uh it's a game but sadly
as most of even if we play it uh we'll
get attacked for any
lame excuse anyway yeah so he was there
for eight hours he was
playing this live thing yeah and then
next thing i know somebody asked him a
question on the minecraft as he's
playing
and they said said to have you read the
quran and he was like no i haven't
but i i want to i'm intrigued to yeah
and i was like wow that's a good sign
you know
oh oh oh surprise
sorry guys it's the first time i'm
playing this is what i'm going to say
sorry guys i like playing stream games
here so basically he goes i would like
to and i thought that's a very good sign
let's watch this clipping shovel and
come back here while i'm taking out some
killings on
these waste money bro glass the dirtiest
is really ruining it plus once it's lit
up i think it's gonna look hella cozy
that's right i said it hella cozy
have i read the quran no i'm curious to
read it though
thank you for asking glad we got that
saddle
so guys what you saw there is him saying
that he's
if you sh
so as you can see um that he's
interested and that's a good sign
because if you think about it somebody
wanting to read it so we thought you
know what look
we can get one sent out to him yeah if
we can get in contact with him we can
get the one sent out to him yeah
all right man just that again yeah we
can get some one action
uh inshallah through ira or other
organizations all we have to do is we're
going to give him a link and he only
needs to apply that and get sent to his
address so his address is not shown to
anybody
okay yes so now one thing else he said
in that game which is very intriguing so
he's building this
massive complex thing that's what he's
doing for like
four hours yeah and he put a little
effort and it looks really crisp i'm not
gonna lie it was very good
but something really clicked for me
because let's watch this clippy and this
clip he goes
he goes yes guys i finally built it
watch this clip let's come back here
watch this inshallah quickly
whoa let me play completely reflection
okay guys i built it
what i would be there so guys what did
you what you guys saw there
as you can see is that he
said soprano he spent hours hours and
hours
building yeah okay
yes so he spent hours building and i was
like wow isn't that a sign
that god exists because imagine this
year imagine someone in that game
minecraft
coming and saying you know what um
they're coming oh man got dead above
i got shut up yeah imagine somebody
coming and seeing
that god doesn't exist yeah guys let me
just clarify what i meant there
what i meant is imagine somebody says in
the game or
there's a creature in the game and says
oh this came by chance
yeah imagine some guy whoever might know
whoever he's called in this minecraft
yeah
imagine there's a character there and he
says nope pewdiepie you didn't make this
it just came by trance it's just been
there you can't say i didn't mean
um that god doesn't exist like imagine
somebody said that
pewdiepie doesn't exist just because he
can't see pewdiepie outside the game
and he denies oh this just this complex
just came by chance
i'm trying to say of course pewdiepie is
going to what are you talking about i
did it that was my point sorry guys i've
been
to this the first time i've done a video
with the game and trying to play at the
same time so i didn't get my message
across properly
hope that clarifies let's carry on
watching yeah just as pewdiepie he was
doing this for hours on end and hours on
end yeah
okay i was on the end he was building
and he was like wow guys finally
finished it yeah and it was a massive
complex
that shows design if there's a design
not only design it shows purpose
there was a purpose pewdiepie was doing
that yeah oh man got killed
you guys can see how it could be this is
uh
it shows design it shows purpose
therefore it requires a design and the
designer was who
pewdiepie and i found that really really
amazing and interesting
because it shows the existence of god in
the context of
cause and effect it didn't come from
nothing but couples he did it himself
for hours for four hours the guy was
doing the design he was looking at each
spot how he just do it
and he was having comments there someone
said i think you did it wrong here he
said where the weather did wrong
that shows you that subhanallah
pewdiepie if he's playing that minecraft
game like it shows you
that it's it's it's some people might
think it's like literally no
it shows you there's design this purpose
there's a design the god exists and he
wants to read the quran
we need to get the quran and i need you
guys
what are you mad yeah so sorry guys a
little jin has a quick time let's do
let's do another program with this guy i
would realize
well this guy died okay that's an
immediate way to die
what are you mad i'm playing good at
this anyways the reason i did the video
in this theme guys is because
pewdiepie plays like this et cetera they
did my journey has a quick time
yeah and i'm gonna end on that note guys
you can see how i died but guys on the
on on serious note if you guys enjoyed
this kind of video
i can do more i'm not sure how good it
was how much you enjoyed it yeah
but the point is this guy's yeah send
this to please to pewdiepie
and we want to get him a quran we're
going to send him a link with that link
inshallah we're going to get him a
package about everything to do with
islam yeah all he has to do is
go there and apply to inshallah and get
his sent oh you know what
if he wants to go and get himself maybe
we can somehow arrange it we're just
here to
facilitate yeah but we would highly
encourage him to read the quran
inshallah and open your eyes and one
thing please pewdiepie pewdiepie
pewdiepie yes
please before you read the quran once
you get your hands on it whenever you do
we ask allah to get
fire us or somebody else we shall get
the rewards please do one thing i did
this [ __ ] to islam
before you open to read the quran say oh
god
if you are there and this is the truth
from you
guide me to it that's a covenant between
you and god now
god is going to send you signs and it's
upon you to take those signs or reject
it
so pewdiepie hope you kind of enjoyed my
little
i'm not good at this yeah i tried my
best you know shooting some people uh
but
that's it guys so i hope you guys
enjoyed it please send that video to him
in the meantime guys
you know everyone's carrying watching
you can kind of watch it but i'm going
to yeah to them the salaam alaikum where
i'm going to tell you about
you guys yes oh the battle victory
finished we won
oh we won oh they finished we won guys
i'm the lightning shallow we can win in
the hair after
guys while you're playing these games do
not forget to pray salah very important
till next time
assalamu alaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh please give comment section
below did you like this video would you
rather do similar videos like this or
playing games is it more interactive for
you guys for the young audience please
get in contact with me
let me know in the comment section until
next time send this to pewdiepie
don't lie